[موسيقى]
يمكنك مشاهدة المدينة بأكملها في صورة واحدة ،
كل شيء بدءًا من تمثال
الحرية وصولاً إلى سنترال
بارك وهو حقًا المكان الوحيد
في المدينة حيث يمكنك الحصول على عرض
لجميع الرموز الرئيسية و  المدينة بأكملها في
لقطة واحدة ونفس واحد
[موسيقى]
أنا أقف على أرضية زجاجية
وربما تكون هذه واحدة من أفضل المساحات التي
لدينا إذا نظرت إلى الأسفل يمكنني النظر إلى الأسفل
على ارتفاع 1100 قدم وصولاً إلى
شارع 10th وهذا هو  حقًا
منظر فريد وتجربة فريدة يمكنك
الوقوف حولها ومشاهدة السيارات التي تسير بجانبها ،
وأعتقد أن الكثير من الأشخاص
سيضعون صورًا ذاتية من أعلى ، وستصبح
هذه اللقطة الشهيرة
[موسيقى]
بمجرد أن تصل إلى القمة.
لن نشجع الناس حقًا على
تركها ، سنسمح للناس
بتجربة ذلك بالطريقة التي يريدون ،
وسيأتي بعض الأشخاص سريعًا جدًا ونحن نعلم أنه
خلال وقت غروب الشمس سيبقى الناس
لفترة أطول قليلاً
ولكننا سنسمح بذلك حقًا  تشعر
بالعضوية ولا تحاول إدارة الناس
بمجرد ر  مرحبًا ، اصعد إلى القمة عندما
تنظر إلى الخارج ، فأنت لا ترى أي درابزين ، أي
قضبان ، أي شيء مثل هذا الزجاج نفسه
هو الهيكل وقد تم
تصميمه بالفعل لعدد من الأسباب ولكن السبب
الرئيسي هو تقديم عرض دون عائق
كما تعلمون  نطلق على أنفسنا حافة عندما
تخرج ، يبدو الأمر حقًا كما لو أنه يمكنك
السير إلى الحافة ، فنحن لا نريد حقًا
أن يفكر الناس فينا على أننا منصة مراقبة ،
لدينا عدد من التجارب
التي نحاول حقًا أن نكون أكثر من
ذلك  وتعطي حقًا نوعًا مختلفًا من
الخبرة ، فهذا يتعلق حقًا
بوجود عناصر فريدة فريدة من نوعها بالنسبة لنا
هنا في Hudson Yards وفريدة من نوعها
، والنظر إلى المدينة هو
المكان الوحيد
الذي يمكنك القيام به فيه  في نيويورك
[موسيقى]